I'm in the center that's what if you
don't move to the left alright hogging
with scream yeah [ __ ] with the right
scream and my favorite moment in the
film it's actually when Jesus Christ
appears and says apes and humans are
equal
hey Starbucks
I'm Ryan right I'm Adele welcome to
reasons to see we give you reasons to
see or maybe not to see dawn of the
Planet of the Apes
so let's hang out so guys Adele and I
just watched dawn of the Planet of the
Apes together singing hello and movie
theater made out for like 20 minutes it
was awesome yeah good really like this
movie an awful [ __ ] lot too much this
movie should be destroyed for how much
it is light yeah it was awesome it had
me the whole time and I loved it and
this is coming from someone who like I
have seen most of the other movies I did
see the last movie you Rise of the
Planet of the Apes but I didn't love it
enough that it's fresh in my mind I
can't really recall anything except
James Franco yeah so yeah this movie
rocked I loved it from the very
beginning it's great you know they have
one of those awesome like zombie like
prologues
we're like the enviros spread across the
nation and that was cool but then like
the opening shot from then on I was
hooked like that first 15 minutes I'm
pretty sure is solid 15 minutes you
didn't see a single human it was just
these Apes and the Apes the first few
minutes and I was like I think I could
just watch the Apes the entire movie and
they and they mainly give you the Apes
as the main character like they're the
main characters you don't go though the
humans are the main characters but it's
really about the Apes it's like no they
it is it's really smart to have that
first 15 minutes just focused on the
Apes because it just gives you time to
get to know them to empathize with them
and then suddenly the humans come in
you're like whoa humans chill out
because it's one thing to understand
where the apes are coming from it's
nothing to feel where they're coming
right now and they really do give you
that feeling and when the human finally
does come in that was perfect I was like
great way to introduce it they put you
like in a world that you feel like
you're just part of this ape community
and then when a human shows up you're
like whoa a human and even though you're
know it's gonna happen eventually it's
still like whoa I didn't expect to be a
little surprised here that was smart
choice that he shot the ape cuz like
right off the bat you know it's like as
a writing point of view it makes the
audience immediately feel like ooh
he inspected up we're okay at the human
Specter but I'm glad they didn't just
focus on the humans [ __ ] it up you
know they everyone was accountable both
sides it wasn't black and white it was
like a real world of societies trying to
function in a world where they just have
to survive you know it's kind of like
the walking dead in a way so they have
to have like what you're talking about
the accountability and that's like it's
just like real people in this film real
people real people real characters man
it was very very character-driven mm-hmm
that's what made it's so exciting like
edge-of-your-seat like exciting like in
the first one it was like there were
some other cool Apes and but it was just
mainly Caesar and this one you do get a
lot of other ones like Caesar's son is
really cool he was a great character
[ __ ] really soft on the eyes mm-hm
like the eyes was so well done and the
characters I don't know that CG work was
amazing I what speaking of eyes what's
his uh what's the thing blue eyes blue
eyes blue eyes was great you know like
they have this Mel has such good settled
because you could kind of feel that
koba's a little bit of a bad day front
and when he's like run away in the
beginning Caesar says think before you
act
and he's like [ __ ] listen to you dad
and then a moment later Koba comes up to
him puts his Pat's him on the shoulder
and he's like hey we all need scars or
some cool [ __ ] like that
you know so it's like immediately
establishing that what do you call it oh
my competitive lion game that's what you
did I said it was like that dynamic of a
father son and the uncle who's kind of a
bit shady so you got Mufasa Simba and
scar yeah no that is very that's very
much in the foster survive most of the
movie yeah yeah and Cobra even had this
like wicked scar on his face yeah
everyone I and
like blue coming I thought COBOL is
written so well like even him he's
essentially who becomes the bad guy yeah
but even then I was like I completely
get word this guy's coming from and they
establish it so well like he's only
learned bad things from humans like why
else would he not trust them like it's
real trauma this dude has it in so it
it's understandable I'm like the first
couple guys who kills really has this
misguided sense of what's right and
wrong it even gets convoluted along the
way through the war he stopped killing
Apes but he just doesn't see it he's
blinded by it oh yeah like do when he
[ __ ] kills ash when he just I thought
he was gonna like take the pole and beat
the humans and then I felt like the
riders were like what if he killed the
ape instead dragging the ape and the
rose him like a kid that was so [ __ ]
up I that actually had my jaw drop a
little bit I couldn't believe that he
just did that and the look on blue eyes
face when that happens it's like you
know sure confusion yeah everyone knows
Andy Serkis is gonna rock it a Caesar
but these other guys to whoever they
were I don't know who played them yeah
they did a great job to Koba and blue
eyes fantastic [ __ ] this film just had a
habit of getting better and better and
better
there was a really good yeah I love that
moment when the Apes decide because I
love seeing the whole leadership
mentality of Caesar makes it a way more
unique experience too so when Cesar
decides to go pay the humans a visit and
he brings all the Apes with him and
stuff like that was a really cool scene
like okay I'll take a break cuz then
with Jason flohrs eyes oh you know he
just walks up there there's a lot of
staring this lost area
oh yeah it's misty I know the female
character follow Keri Russell the feds
like three scenes she's in like all she
does is tear up and cry yeah
she's not a very strong woman in a
female character but I'm hoping there's
like a director's cut where you do get
to explore these characters more like a
really good director's cut I loved those
moments of Caesar with his family like
not the heat like his actual family it
was cool let's see like oh he has a wife
and a kid now two kids now I like those
moments I wish we got to see a little
bit more of the wife letter than she's
sick and we care about her because she's
Caesar's wife and she has a baby other
than having a couple of facts about her
you really care about
so yeah the female characters are not
really explored that much but I'm hoping
there's like a director's cut read you
get explore them it's kind of okay I
don't know I didn't really miss a female
presence Oh feel like I'm glad they
didn't just write some you know some
[ __ ] Apes that's relying the female
character in just for the sake of you
know representing it felt well-balanced
because it's a very male testosterone
dominated well that's happening yeah how
so horny watching it ridiculously horny
yeah so ceases family I love the little
baby baby that same thing the baby gets
off the horse and comes connects with
the humans connects with the Keri
Russell and the little boy the teenage
boy character and it's like oh maybe we
can just all get along no you can't yeah
douche bag McGee [ __ ] yeah decides to
grab a shotgun like an idiot yeah like
that was one moment where like I hated
that guy and you're supposed to that was
one more like he says it yeah what I'm
the [ __ ] like he knows he's the arse
oh god I [ __ ] hated that guy
I like legitimately was like your
[ __ ] things up for something you
gotta cut it out there's always people
that don't conform to the main group and
don't do what you want them to do you
know they're always gonna go off and do
their own thing and ruin things for
everybody else yeah [ __ ] they're in
both the good you know the humans versus
the Apes
there were singular sort of mines that
stuck out it's like the bad characters
so the Apes that was Koba in the humans
you had Drake Dreyfus which is Gary
Oldman's character they're very very
similar type of characters even though
they're on both sides of the wharf and I
really liked
they showed their similarities it shows
that they're just so similar these
babies apes and humans are so similar
I feel like we're Gary Oldman's
character that he could have felt a
little more necessary but it's still
good and Gary Oldman for the little bits
he has he still decides to go embody
this role he has that one moment where
he's looking at his family photos and
the whole thing is done in silence he's
just looking around the computer and and
then he starts to cry
yeah and it's like Utah it just makes
you really understand more where this
dude's coming from like he's had to go
through a lot of [ __ ] to survive just
like kirbo I mean just like count apart
karma is also what in the first movie
which I can't really remember Kirby's
been experimented on and anal probing
was awfully did that like another scene
that I thought was so good was like you
know cuz Caesar has like really well
written in her complan confliction
between his you know draw to humans
because [ __ ] grew up with humans and
you know that hurt and betrayal that he
also has so like when he's helping out
the humans a lot and then when Koba
comes back after seeing that they are
the humans have all the guns and then
they get into that fight that was this
really strong moment because you get
where both of those dudes are coming
from in that moment you know like you
just don't [ __ ] with a guy's family like
that you don't tell a guy you love the
humans more than your son ouch I really
felt like I was in an Apes position in
that okay first off that was just a
violent [ __ ] scene like when Cesar's
thrashing on him I'm like you can get
away with this because they're Apes but
if these were humans this would be
incredibly violent yeah and like even
koba's like bleeding a little bit he's
already got a fucked-up face enough as
it is
earlier in the film you see come over
each other's hand for forgiveness and
that's what that means and then Caesar
just like [ __ ] smacks with like the
cool G that he is and then and then in
that moment the same thing was offered
but it was like but shit's not really
cool yeah shit's really no yeah no
there's something about the way they
touch each other's hands you're just not
sure about anymore look really clever
plots are and went
you forget his name kava-kava Kobe
Bryant Kobe Bryant when he takes the gun
shoots the Caesar and then see you think
Caesar is that of course you don't know
but he shoots Caesar and then he just
leaves it and stuff and he puts on this
act like what the [ __ ] someone shot
Caesar and it was so so smart I'm like
clever bad guy that is a clever bad guy
yeah I love that the bad guys they were
just so the Cobo was so well-rounded
yeah you hated him cuz he was the bad
guy and he was doing [ __ ] up things
but at the same time he could still just
see a glimpse of where he was coming
from my only one thing about it was I
felt like Koba eventually started to
lose some of his humanity you know and
it's like then he'd be kind of became
villain that's drunk with power
right and I didn't really believe the
drunk with power heart because I was
like this didn't seem like it was uh
like being the king of things it seemed
like it was a thing of really defense
and wanting to take them out of survival
reasons because he's a fear and stuff so
drunk with power
I was not it was just something I didn't
fully believe at the time that's fair
yeah we gonna have a fight damn good
review show now I just saw that that was
the only way that I felt like they could
take it and then kill him and it'd be
okay with the audience that see that's
what I mean they had to stop showing the
lightness you know they're just stops
giving us any more empathy towards him
otherwise when he died it would have
been not okay yeah no that's what I mean
is like I would have preferred a more
challenging ending like that okay like
cuz that's where I thought this one was
cool cuz I'm like this isn't your
typical Hollywood film right but I could
see how were the best like two in a
million dollar picture like a little
safe but yeah the ending was safe but it
was satisfying still yeah I was still
satisfying and like at the end of day
you don't want Kobe to die cuz he was a
douchebag
he's really good with guns though I
liked that one moment was riding the
horse and you got both gun
like I don't like him scary badass oh my
god oh my god I I kind of wish they
hadn't spoiled that for me in the
trailer because that would have that was
just such a crazy image the action
scenes are so good because they're not
just like awesomely directed they're
also like emotionally gripping like I
was getting anxiety during that first
battle yeah I was like oh my god Cesar's
like probably asleep right now all this
shit's going down like no the war the
war started in that first battle scene
I loved the bit where Koba gets in on
the tank and he like pulls that dude out
of the tank and like crushes his sternum
and whatever and then they do this 360
tank fit while the tanks going and the
camera is like it feels like point of
view where the cameras like sitting on
top of the tank is the tank head is
rotating around you see all the
battlefield in the background but even
before the 360 tank part like the guy
tries climbing out of the tank just
holding back anything murder the dude
like oh yeah I love that attention to
detail like definitely say like
first-person point of view or something
in that battle as well just before the
tank bit again when the humans are
gearing up for battle I thought they did
this really nice little bit because it's
not a lot of time to go into detail you
know there's so much happening but they
just throw in this tiny little detail of
Gary Oldman like helping this young boy
looks like a teen like get his weapons
in order and you know it's gonna be okay
and then we cut back to it a few minutes
later and the boy is like dead eyes open
blood everywhere
and just really shows that brutality of
war I like that they don't glorify war
in this at all they've definitely show
how awful an oval it is it's just like
some survival story of like society's
fighting for territory so we're just to
fight out of fear the whole time we're
thinking if these guys just had a
sit-down conversation yeah probably uh
probably wouldn't get into all this [ __ ]
isn't that it isn't that why it was
stopped because because we can't
communicate probably communicate yeah
that's a lot of miscommunication and a
lot of misunderstandings
the whole thing really is a
misunderstanding and that's what is so
tragic about it all is that can't we all
just get along
the [ __ ] got serious oh wait oh god I
mentioned eight battle at the end
[ __ ] fantastic it was like watching
two eights fighting did not expect that
yeah big square of final battle to be
between two Apes which was just so cool
it was well choreographed yeah it was
well stylized in there I believed a
hundred percent I never for one one
second thought that there was computer
stuff going on it wasn't like yeah
you're so invested you completely forget
their computer characters I totally
forget that was my problem with avatar I
was so aware that they were computer the
whole time mm-hmm I couldn't get into it
like as really space but that's good
exactly these are these are Apes kind of
it's a little bit more close to home sir
just a little bit though a little bit
yeah yeah That moment when Caesar and
his son make up when he starts to cry
when they're in James Franco's old house
yeah I almost cried but I did it but I
you did yeah it was very moving you know
cuz they have a complicated relationship
at the beginning they don't see eye to
eye there's this son bristly act trying
to outdo his father and doesn't want to
be treated like a child anymore he's
getting manipulated now yeah and then
suddenly he's able to come into his own
stand out that's cool man yeah good
Redemption when he [ __ ] is like I'm
gonna break those Apes out and bring
them over you're dead how good are your
brain eating ape oh he's cool his voice
didn't I don't know whatever anything
sound like but he had this kind of voice
that sounded a bit like that's what a
chord sounds like no we have like a
funny like boys yeah
I was thinking the same thing that's not
how talking apes sound final moments in
this film I thought were really good I
thought it was a great way to set up for
a sequel and because it's it's bringing
it full circle and in a different route
than you would have expected because um
rise of the plight of the apes based off
the way it was ending I just thought the
sequel would be like Cesar's gonna kick
some human ass but you see in this one
he's like no I'm just trying to live my
own ape life right now and stay away
from humans and then the cause of this
war like oh it's so smart how Cesar was
even like hey it's our fault for going
war we [ __ ] up but now we got to
defend ourselves yeah he takes
responsibility but at the same time he's
not gonna step down and just let his
people die you know and it's still
they're still having understanding and
then like that growth of him like
accepting the fact that like Apes and
humans are hey we all got emotions and
we all [ __ ] up
that was cool when it is like a friend
Cesar quoits
what else is Caesar's okay so Adelie do
people say that's him yeah
Adelie yeah you sound like a deli a deli
yeah a deli what do you want mom turkey
ham that's trow me that's good
that's the first time I heard you do an
accent yeah so Adele what do you think
the reasons are to see this movie
everything I would have to agree this to
me is the reason movies are made I got
nothing I'm just stare off get
misty-eyed
I was trying to get there alright guys
thanks for checking out our review for
none of what it is why don't you go
ahead and comment below and tell us what
would your eighth name be that's a good
question what would your name be a long
stock long long that's the one yeah I
would be Carly well II we just want our
names to rhyme and if you want to see it
more episodes of reasons to see ya
reasons reasons many reasons to see make
sure you click the link below to
subscribe that's correct
and Adele has her own movie review
channel you should check out her channel
here's another link for that right here
seriously she does give reviews
obviously why would she come on the
channel if she sucked
why don't make a sucking joke right now
right
oops last but not least if you want to
get update every time one of our reviews
or videos is out subscribe click on this
button to subscribe
yeah right there there you go there you
go you look like you're pushing a
woman's boobs away from your face right
now oh you're so tall and fat huh
you're dating a fat guy I got nothing
you got nothing so you haven't I feel
like your camera battery's running out
no that's not a feeling that's just the
fact but I feel it I felt it before I
saw it yeah I just feel like I've been
like switched on really concentrate I
did not I honestly did not even think
about that till I saw it your eyes go
it's like why are we done
can I go now I'm gonna keep recording so
you're done
hey you have to walk home man so you got
to relax for a while get Starbucks
you just had Starbucks and it didn't
help you at all I want more Starbucks
okay I'm just doing this to torture you
okay [ __ ] it with us now lucky with the
dish